foreign
[Music]
we have about 196 capsules on board that
flight along with uh Gene Roddenberry
and his wife majel's ashes a couple
other Star Trek celebrities like Jimmy
Doohan who played uh Scotty Michelle
Nichols who played Lieutenant and
um
DeForest Kelly who played Bones
[Music]
it's going to be the first and only
repository of our civilization out in
the universe no one's done that before
[Music]
we all want to be immortal in some way
and this was an opportunity for us to be
able to do something that no one else
has done to go where no one else has
gone before our DNA will go into deep
space it will be the furthest Human
Genome from the planet
[Music]
so this is the DNA Memorial kit and
basically it takes the DNA it creates a
substrate a powdered substrate that's
capable of Intergalactic travel you know
because you don't have heaters on board
you have to have the DNA that's in a
powdered form that can handle the rigors
of space
[Music]
even though we're not going to be there
physically
we're going to be a little part of it in
some way and that really does make me
smile
[Music]